كان الفخر كبيرا والامل كبير بالنسبه
لكثيرين بعد مسار المشرف واداء مشرف يخرج
اسود الاطلس من انتصار الى انتصار مباراه
تاريخيه ساخنه مشحونه امام جمهور احمر
بنسبه 80% في الملعب والانجاز ايضا تاريخي
نصف نهائي في قطر لاعبوا المغرب نافسو
انفسهم اولا نافسه حواجز الخوف امام
افواجا من عمالقه الكره عبر البطوله
وكسروا ارقام الخصوم وارقامهم الشخصيه
المغرب يخسر امام حامل اللقب فرنسا لكنها
ليست نهايه الرحله انما هي بدايه جديده
للكره العربيه
رفعتم سقف احلامنا كثيرا وغدا لن يكون
كامس وكلمه منا في صباح العربيه الكتب
واحاديث الناس ستتذكر مراتكم غير المسبوقه
و ستحفظها للابد في سجلات قصص المونديال
المذهله انتم ابطال واستحقيتم كل ثانيه من
ذلك الانجاز فاستمتعوا وعود الينا في
الميداليه الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
ان شاء الله مازال ما غايعطيونا بزاف ديال
الحوايج ان شاء الله
كاتحرق النجاح وكاتعدها دائما المشفر
دائما الى القمه ان شاء الله بالمنتخب
ديالنا المغربي
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]